connaissez-vous le mythe de la veuve
noire une histoire de misogynie de
xénophobie à la cour de france
[Musique]
au 16ème siècle catherine de médicis et
et la régie lumière des puissants
medicine de florence mais c'est la
raison pour laquelle cette nièce qui par
clémence est destinée à épouser le futur
roi de france henri viii un mariage qui
va bien deux jeunes amoureux
une jeune fille qui apporte de
l'originalité la cour de france mais
cette histoire se termine en 1559
lorsque le roi en route 17 18 de
l'accident de jeu à partir de ce moment
là catherine de médicis décident qu'ils
ne passent à blick en noir et qu'elle
veut porter le deuil de son mari jusqu'à
sa mort et les veuves et elle doit
assumer la régence du royaume de france
en attendant que ces faits soient en âge
de régner
ce qui n'est pas pour plaire en fait une
partie la noblesse et de la population
française
parce que non seulement c'est une femme
qui veut régner sur le royaume de france
mais aussi une étrangère une italienne
n'en fallait pas plus pour que le mythe
de la veuve noire commence à prendre
racine un peu partout en france
alors on commence à dire que le des
plantes machiavélique pour se
débarrasser de ses ennemis
il faut dire qu'elle consulte des
astrologues et des devins notamment le
très célèbre nostradamus la veuve noire
porte aussi des gants de cuir et la
rumeur commence à se répandre qu'il a
trouvé une recette chimique afin de les
induire de poison ce qui lui permet de
se débarrasser de ses ennemis d'une
seule une poignée de main il faut dire
que là sur la région sont plein coeur
des sanglantes guerres de religion en
france entre les protestants c'était un
gros niveau problème a choisi de faire
épouser sa fille la princesse marguerite
au roi protestant de navarre le futur
roi henri iv
ce mariage entre la reine margot et le
roi henry vont mener à l'exécution des
protestants dans les rues de paris
ce qu'on appelle le massacre de la saint
barthélemy il faut aussi ajouter qu'au
19e siècle
des auteurs comme balzac et surtout
alexandre guillemant avec la publication
du roman la reine margot oomu c'est en
fait ce personnage
il n'en fallait pas plus pour que la
légende de la veuve noire machiavélique
méchante s'imprégnant fait dans
l'imaginaire collectif
mais les historiens et alice que le tout
fait pour essayer de régler les guerres
de religion et il est vraiment difficile
de prouver qu'elle ait pu réussir en dur
ses gants de poison